♪ [intro music] ♪
Looking to manage access
to your organization's
Google Cloud resources with ease?
Give me one minute and I'll show you how
with Cloud Identity
and Access Management.
Cloud Identity and Access Management
enables you to grant access
to cloud resources at fine-grain levels
and gives you visibility and tools
for centrally managing
your cloud resources.
Access can be granted to resources
based on attributes like resource type,
so that users get access
only to what they need
to get the job done.
IAM provides a unified view
into security policy
across your entire organization
with built-in auditing to easy
your compliance processes.
Use Cloud IAM with Resource Manager
to easily modify your access policies
for your organization,
folders, and projects.
Built-in policy intelligence,
machine learning and automation tools
help you reduce your risk.
For example, IAM Recommender
automatically detects
overly permissive access
and helps you rightsize.
Cloud IAM Resource Manager
and the tools and policy intelligence
are available in the Cloud Console,
gcloud command line tool,
and programmatically through REST APIs.
So next time you're looking
to smartly and efficiently
manage secure access
to your cloud deployment,
take a minute to look at Cloud IAM.
To learn more, check out
cloud.google.com/iam
♪ [outro music] ♪